Chancellor Merkel is in the firing line
after opening Germany's borders to
Syrian refugees members of our own party
say her actions have only intensified
the influx of migrants by changing
Germany's asylum laws especially
regarding applicants from Western Balkan
countries German interior minister
thomas de Mesilla hopes to slow the
influx of migrants well that's its air
does fit detaining Denis the reforms
will apply to those who are due to be
repatriated and are no longer entitled
to apply for a silent but don't leave
the contrast and understeer in that case
Island they will only receive the
absolute bare essential simba
Northlander go ahead the Christian
Democrats expressed concern at how tens
of thousands of Muslim migrants could be
integrated into german society that's
going to guess it's the Constitution is
above any religion men and women are
equal everyone has the right to live and
live as they like and it's not the
Prophet Muhammad that says these laws in
Germany our laws are passed here by us
in Parliament magnetic famine and Karen
but the Green Party warned against any
right-wing populism the adulation guy
anyone who resurrects the ghosts of
right-wing nationalism will never be
able to control it with the majority in
parliament the government's reform
package is all but certain to be
approved the laws are expected to come
into force on the first of November